so everyone's been telling me I have to
review this movie so here it is
insidious so insidious is a story of a
family that's haunted by a demon because
the demon wants their kid now whenever
believe this movie is being compared to
paranormal activity but I don't think
that's really fair comparing insidious
to paranormal activities kind of like
comparing Godzilla to Cloverfield both
are better than Godzilla but I'm just
saying they're shot differently one shot
like a mockumentary the other shot like
a cinematic movie this is like the
cinematic movie version of paranormal
activity and in that is it better is it
worse is it scarier is it not all right
so the movie is creepy for the first
half or so I thought it was a little
slow but it was really subtle in the way
it scared people like paranormal
activity and I like that stuff then
stuff starts happening and then it picks
up and you're like I as genuinely creepy
movie like me when I got home I was like
all the movies all rise pretty scary
then I start shutting the bedroom doors
turning on the lights and turn on
the TV for some ambient noise it's not
creepy the other cooking channel so
when that the movie does do its job it
is a creepy movie now the main
difference between this and Paranormal
Activity is that it shows the demon now
at first it's all subtle things are in
the background behind curtains and
whatnot and then it shows the demon and
I'm not gonna lie to you guys I was like
holy it's Darth Maul I'm sure
you've heard that before but come on
it's Darth Maul Darth Maul was creepy
even when it shows him he's creepy I'm
saying I would have rather have seen him
in like paintings and drawings and just
left it at that and I like it when
movies don't show with a thing in it cuz
it's as creepy as your mind can possibly
make it up to be doesn't mean this movie
does not have the creeped out factor
because it does its you've seen
before but it is creepy stuff at a point
it kind of felt like a zombie movie
though or a funhouse fright like the
climax of the movie reminds me of a
really cool haunted house that I haven't
seen so if anyone out there can make a
haunted house like that props to you and
I found the whole concept of the movie
interesting it wasn't like you know
demon and kid and demon wants the kid
cuz there was more to it than that I
like that so the first half creepier
than the second half the second half
more entertaining than the first half if
that makes sense the climax of the movie
was straight up I swear to God it must
have been directed by Rob Zombie I just
find it creepier when things are like
flashed on the screen for like one frame
and you go back and rewind it you're
like holy that's the creepiest
thing I've ever seen when it shows
everything on the screen it stops being
creeping - starts being cool so I will
say if Paranormal Activity bored you
then this has more going on in it so
it's not going to bore you as much if
you like paranormal activity the way it
is and you think it's just perfectly
creepy because it doesn't show anything
you might be a little disappointed but
are going to be entertained and
case the movie is cool and it does its
job well so I would say the movie is a
good time no alcohol required in a
really good way scariest movie ever of
the past decade whatever people are
calling it I don't think so I didn't get
creeped out in this movie more than I
did the first time I saw a paranormal
activity also that it all depends on
what you look for but if you like what
you seen here you want to see more click
right here to see more what keep looking
over there